thank you
[Music]
who here actually uses Tick Tock some
not really I don't really guilty you do
yeah do you go on Tick Tock live no I
never did take the line do you know I
never done anything live do you are you
guys aware of the kind of weird [__]
that's on ticked out like people
sleeping some people they're like have
you seen a girl that's right now that's
going viral with like uh she's like has
a cucumber and it's like the cucumber's
like been slopped out but she's like
saying like kick some [__] get some
lights I need more likes I need more
followers and I'm gonna like Gog off
this 3000 yeah and I've
but it looks like I mean it's foamed up
all that [__] she chokes on it I guess
so I've never got to see it but she's
always popping up on my [__] she's
probably in there right now but look
that's why your feet are it's like
another
it really leaves like another
like an example if you guys don't really
see it
um one example is interactive sleep
streams I've seen those yeah that was
weird that was weird too they're just
sleeping or sleeping oh that gamer girl
make a [__] ton of money off of just
sleeping yeah but then the main thing is
that these are like there's
times Unlimited Supply of people doing
that that they're not famous all they do
is okay look at this so you'll just
you'll be sleeping like this right and
you'll have options kind of around the
or to make to wake them up pick them up
in different ways and you basically just
torture yourself
that's hilarious it's like dunk tank
[__] yeah
you just set it up with your with your
app with your computer oh with your apps
so certain things if like I donate like
a rose or I donate an ice cream or
something which are worth certain
amounts of points different things so
like torments okay really cool though
yeah that's pretty fun I wonder how they
program that what if they're just
pretending that they're tired and trying
to sleep but really they're awake just
collecting money in all the awkward ways
that's another thing so um in addition
to that there are also like uh weird
things like there's this one scam where
it's um third world countries that look
like it'll be like a guy showing his
sick kid no oh yeah
he's like crafted toilet papers
thank you thank you when they donated
that's a good racket though it is a
great racket but the funny thing is is
it's like uh it's not even real like not
that the kid's not real yeah but it's a
loop
playing on dozens of different accounts
so smart nothing's even real so these
everything all of these a lot of these
are a lot of them I've been watching uh
I've been stuck on a couple of Warzone
videos and I'm just like thinking it's
real and then I was like wait rebirth
island has been gone
this is live and then I'll get excited
I'll look at them like it's back and I
go in it's like [__] liar so it'd be
like this that kid that kid like you'll
just see like a guy going like please
help my son or something but it's like
not even not only is that not real but
you're not even watching it live oh wow
people are so good at scamming yeah it
gets they're getting better there's a
lot you could donate on tick tock
he's like are these guys [__] serious
yeah yeah they're so [__] old because
I feel like people been donating like
I'll [__] do live [__] anymore but on
YouTube you can like if you're a
neighbor yeah you could do live episodes
and stuff and you can get like little
Badges and [__] like Badges and people
pay you and stuff
yeah not that I've ever paid for a badge
there's a lot of weird things and
there's also like people that do another
common thing on Tick Tock live is
they'll do like Gem and rock sales have
you seen those where they'll have like a
kind of like a basket and then they'll
be selling like precious stones and [__]
that are like Jade or Malachite and then
literally
um they'll just like if you buy it then
they'll scoop like a grab bag of stones
for you and it [__] goes for hours
wow oh no have you seen the one that
it's uh the quarters you know how you
know they're playing oh yeah the one
that I love that [__]
yeah well those ones are crazy people go
nuts over those you know what though
it's I think they buy the machine and
then they well that's what they're doing
because like some of them it's just
outrageous they have like gold [__]
bars bricks it's like 50 000 worth of
quarters you know yeah there's even
somewhere like a dude is just clicking
his mouth like this and a counter goes
up and he's trying to get to like nine
trillion oh my God you can donate money
to reset his counter and he's like oh
man what yeah what the [__] I love
telling you about this because you you
probably never it's so stupid yeah I've
never seen any of that kind of [__]
there's one there's another popular one
we're thinking outside the box dude I
don't like just conversation
everybody who's watching this stream
it'll show all of their heads like if
you start watching the stream right
you'll see your head in the icon it'll
be like a bunch of bubbles everybody's
head is in this icon all the bubbles are
getting on this [__] oh yeah and if you
want to get on the ship before everybody
you pay money and you get on the ship
and the ship takes off nothing happens
it's just like a game like it's just
like an it's like a mini uh narcissism
satisfaction people waste money on the
dumbest [__] but the reason I'm bringing
this up because I want to show you guys
uh kind of like a more recent format I
guess you could say that we're gonna do
looks like no we're not doing this [__]
that we're gonna do but it almost looks
like an alien [__] language and I
really just want to uh see what you
think of this
so this is this is the middle of the
live stream okay
it looks kind of like normal also sound
right she can get it oh this has been
going around yeah so but what do you
what do you think of this Bart I common
stinky sweat outside
[Music]
oh she's eating the food
she's eating the comments I'll give her
a hot dog
so those like symbols are like
representative of points that are being
donated but she's actually have a
monetary value she's eating it but she's
she's acting like a [__] cartoon like
a little toy like a little that's like a
thing and she was going young that type
of look and the way she's doing her
facial expression is how like Bella
porch got super famous yeah that's that
anime
I've seen his clip
what is she doing same thing that's what
the context is I dude I was I couldn't
understand what this video is
so good so every donation is the ice
cream
yes yes yes
take your Blade Take Your J's gang gang
so she does different reactions she's
reacting to based on what you're
receiving yeah you get she has like her
like predetermined phrase that I do for
this for this for this right and they
get paid bro they don't just get paid
they get matched I mean shout outs to
them for like yeah falling out and
fitting on a system and crushing it yeah
but it's just it's just crazy to me that
there's people that are sitting there
and like sending [__] donuts and hot
dogs and [__] watching the movie The
Whale yeah yeah those guys are doing it
they're [__]
[__] whack yeah I heard a lot of
people say that dude I was like no
spoilers I do eventually want to watch
it I think the movie is good but the
subject matter is so bad there's no
ditch dude I was like there was a lot of
tits it was his yeah no it wasn't I
watched it in the plane and I just felt
so like uncomfortable it's sad it's a
very sad movie you're just watching a
fat [__] be miserable well you're
understanding the psychological aspect
of this fat [__] dude but I could have
seen I could have thought like that's
like to me it's like duh it's a
no-brainer the [__] the no-brainer yeah
there's nothing there's no new discovery
some of us are trying to lose weight man
any movie review videos by Joe no
[__] Discovery I like his review
would be like uh duh yeah it's a selfish
fat [__] that's it wow special special
give him an Academy Award did you feel
like this form of social media
um does it feel kind of like it's in
line with when you first started doing
social media no it's gone to a different
like it's uh yeah in evolution does it
feel like a d Evolution if you're like a
lateral movement what does it look like
you know what it is to me it's someone
that's done it so long I want to say oh
yeah I want to give you guys opinion on
that because you guys been in the game
longer than I have but I will say that
it's it's creating its own little world
you're creating your own little like
place where you can leave this reality
and go into this weird
weird reality and people are living in
this it's like when you're playing Final
Fantasy or Zelda and then you go off the
main storyline and then you just go into
like a small town you're just playing
random little games and [__] like that
you know what I mean it's just it's I've
never really tell the dude
I'll say right now dude I never played
this is actually part of the trajectory
but I think from the get-go the I
actually related closer to video games
than I do social media and from the
get-go I think I've already been off the
course so like you know like when people
got really into Guitar Hero I'm like why
don't you just learn guitar yeah oh so
people played fictional games I get it
you can't get that in real life but if
you're like if you're playing Super
Mario you again you can't eat a mushroom
get big and dogs cool stuff so you play
the game I understand but then people
that started playing games that they can
do in real life yeah to me it felt I'm
on I'm like oh you're already want to
get plugged in into a virtual reality
space and I have never been on board
even sense like Nintendo so I saw it
grow pre-social media starting then and
I've I've never been on board so when I
see this I'm like oh I could totally see
my friends that I played Nintendo with
that like to be in a different world
really go down this path versus I've
always been more and more real life like
let's go in the forest and do [__] you
know rather than be like a squirrel like
let's go look at real squirrels yeah
that makes sense wow
well yeah because I related more to
video games than social media because
I'm sure people will get a weird
dopamine hit when they when that girl
eats their [__] donut that they don't
you know it's like they're like oh
[__]
ate it or it's so good it's like nothing
else that it feels like it belongs to
that Community yeah yeah it just I feel
like it's just like a modern day
Carnival like but you're you're at home
so like that the first one the wake up
one I don't see that any different from
a dunk tank when you're at a carnival
you pay a few balls and then you try to
like [__] them up yeah and then so like
the even the the other ones the tip ones
it's like you go to a [__] strip club
you throw some money and then she Twirls
she does that [__] thing or like it's
just you're paying these there's a
preset amount of like what you're gonna
get the different tricks the type of
things right yeah and then and now it's
just digital form the only difference is
the guy that's doing the dunk take
imagine this guy was in real life he is
at the dunk day for six hours
he dropped the clown twice on I was
tired okay let's go get a funnel cake or
whatever and you walk away yeah well now
you have a guy that's there that's like
yeah
is they they combine the casino
addiction aspect and how long you know
the casino aspect for kids yeah yeah but
it's like a
I think it's grown man they're like
getting off of like having control of a
person and the other day humans just
love to control yeah and it's their way
of saying like they're gay they get off
of like if I give her this amount of
money she's gonna do some goofy [__] she
has to do some goofy [__] do this for me
now be dumb it's like yeah that's right
and he keeps doing it it's like his way
of like I'm controlling this [__] right
now and it's like I exist a lot of money
I would get
to make her dance there's even like they
get off of that [__] there's even like
really really simple ones where it's
just two halves of a screen one side
just says girls one side says guys and
you just donate to make the number go up
so that one gets the other see and it's
infinite see that's the best one
probably like it's just something that's
automated there's a genius about all
this yeah yeah there is a Jesus jumping
into the mind of like damn how do I I
don't even know how to sell to a person
like that yeah it's true but they know
how because they're just they're saying
like what the [__]
you're like yo this is girl we're gonna
she's gonna do some weird [__] with her
tongue and you can if you get the [__]
away from me dude
that'll work yeah this is not gonna work
dude that's just kind of how you know
that like your your mind is lapsed at
you're kind of like Beyond being able to
like see this in the same way at least
you know like you're not good I think
there's a chunk of humans that are still
on
yeah I want to live my real life and
there's another chunk of humans are
growing up like I'd rather live the this
internet life yeah yeah and we're when
we're bulging out and we're both
miserable escaping is awesome but the
funny thing is that I feel like now more
than ever we have a climate of people
that do like this yeah because like back
in the day Adults Swim did kind of this
thing where they like had a guy locked
in a room and if you paid certain amount
of money you can give them a trumpet you
can give them a [__] bet that's
[__] you can give them a new outfit
and it was but it was like comic relief
it was like oh that's a fun idea yeah
and you just you were laughing at the
idea of it but you weren't subscribed to
the real right yeah and I also feel like
I I also feel like is this because this
be like is this happening in other
countries like some guy in Russia I bet
it's just like you know [__] room
just going like it's like a human nature
thing yeah
it's generational in China yeah in small
towns because let me tell you something
like when I go to Mexico and I'll go to
like the city part I ran into some weird
people but when I go to like the village
I ran into some weird [__] people
like goat [__] people and I'm like oh
interesting hmm like the human mind at a
[__] Ranch like that just went weird
yeah like he just went off of like
there's not enough humans around and
then to entertain myself to get off of
myself let me [__] it's a weird fish and
I'm like huh you're left alone huh and
when you bring this [__]
to America
the go [__] out of America he goes
one like
just smell it just going off I don't
know dude
I don't [__] know dude